&gt;&gt; Well, this ordered pair, or point would be here. If you got this right, well
done. I haven't even told you about negative coordinates yet. To think about a
negative coordinate, instead of moving right, we want to move left. We move left
because it's the x coordinate. We move in the horizontal direction, this way. So
from the origin, we move three units left and then two units up. I know it can't
be either of these points because well the x coordinate would be positive and
ours is negative, so these are out. The same would be true for this coordinate,
the x value would be positive 3. If you chose this point, you were a close
second. This point is really 3 to the left or negative 3. And then down 2, so
negative 2 in the y direction. But we don't have a negative 2, we have a
positive 2 for our y coordinate. Once we move three units to the left of the
origin, we must move two units up. So one, two.